un carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
saludos y bienvenidos a este nuevo
número de carrusel de las artes desde la
alfombra roja del festival de cine de
cannes alfombra roja por la que
desfilaron decenas de estrellas del
séptimo arte mundial en esta edición
número 75 del festival de cine más
importante del mundo
[Música]
a el festival de cannes 2022 cerros por
todo lo alto su edición número 75 les
contaremos sobre los principales premios
de esta fiesta del cine llevada a cabo
con completa normalidad después de la
comida costa rica estuvo por primera vez
en la selección oficial con domingo y la
niebla proyectada en la sección una
cierta mirada conversamos con el
director y el protagonista de esta cinta
con mucho realismo mágico chile también
estuvo este año en cannes con 1976 la
primera película de manuela martelli que
formó parte de la quincena de los
realizadores
y fuimos al encuentro de la francesa
claire denis quien puso su cámara en
américa central con su cinta stars acnur
[Música]
fueron 12 días para celebrar el cine de
aplausos y de estrellas por la alfombra
roja del festival de cannes una fiesta
que cerró con la tradicional gala de
entrega de los premios la palma
[Aplausos]
el festival de cannes consagró por
segunda vez al sueco rubén oslin quien
se ha convertido en un maestro absoluto
del sí mismo sucinta triángulos arnés se
llevó el sábado por la noche la palma de
oro a la mejor película segunda palma
para el aplaudido director de cine quien
ya había logrado este galardón en 2017
con the square
entre ángulos arnés oslo hizo una aguda
crítica al mundo de la moda y a la
frivolidad de los millonarios algunos
críticos la encontraron grotesca y
exagerada pero lo cierto es que hizo
reír mucho al público de cannes el sueco
ruben ostlund tras recoger su premio
y estoy feliz de escuchar al público
aplaudir
de distintas formas estoy también muy
honrado de que el jurado haya reconocido
este trabajo y que haya entregado la
palma de oro a una cinta compra
[Música]
el jurado presidido por el actor francés
band son landon fue generoso en
galardones otorgando dos grandes premios
uno para stars at noon de la francesa
claire ton y un romance ambientado en
nicaragua otro para close un drama
sensible sobre un dúo de amigos
inseparables que habla de la
construcción de la masculinidad
su director el belga lucas don't have it
so la más killing es una película sobre
la masculinidad y la amistad pocos veces
vemos imágenes sobre la amistad efusiva
que puede existir entre dos chicos con
todo lo que puede tener de íntimo de
físico y de tierno mi película habla de
eso y también de la pérdida de la
ternura
el jurado de cannes resolvió inventar un
nuevo premio el 275 aniversario del
festival para los hermanos jean-pierre y
luc dardenne y sus cintas sobre dos
menores inmigrantes solos en bélgica
también hubo premio del jurado por
partida doble para las 8 montañas y la
fantasía animal y una perla de
creatividad sobre la deambulación de un
burrito nostálgico
el sábado
carne de asia
no lo sé
en 2022 se vio la primera película
costarricense en la selección oficial
del festival de cine de cannes
presentada en la sección una cierta
mirada una cinta filmada en el corazón
de costa rica- y carrusel de las artes
fue el encuentro de quienes la hicieron
posible
dicen que usted es un hombre
domingo y la niebla es el segundo
largometraje de ariel escalante meza una
película filmada en cascajal de coronado
y que cuenta la historia de un viudo que
conversa con su esposa muerta quien se
le aparece bajo la forma de una nube de
niebla a ella le cuenta sus penas y la
perspectiva de ser desalojado de su casa
por una empresa que proyecta a construir
una autopista en la zona ariel escalante
mesa tejió una trama entre duelo y
expropiaciones con un toque de realismo
mágico
[Música]
costa rica es un país que se ve como muy
pacífico y bueno pues es un país que
tiene muchos muchos muchos privilegios
que a mí me encanta hacer de ella pero
también hay mucha violencia también hay
mucha inequidad también hay mucha
desigualdad de la cual no queremos
hablar y me parece que es importante
pues yo quería no aportar un grano de
arena que costa rica reconozca su
violencia reconozca su inequidad y
reconozca su desigualdad injusticia y
empezamos hablar de ellas porque ese
tipo de heridas sólo se curan si
hablamos de ellas queríamos también
hacer una peli muy de fantasía no muy
muy sobre muertos que vuelven a la vida
a hacer efectos especiales no entonces
como que a fin de cuentas lo que
queríamos era hacer una película muy
punk sabes o sea una película que
tuviera de todo tiene un poco de western
tiene drama de personaje es fantástica
no porque realmente nos gusta el
conflicto no nos gusta el contraste nos
gusta la pelea era pues
tanto que es que la carretera pase por
aquí en el papel del viudo que conversa
con la niebla el actor carlos ureña que
es un personaje muy rico
de digamos de un pueblo que realmente
uno lo ve muy común en los pueblos
largos de la montaña con los problemas
de la construcción de carreteras
y con el problema de la vivienda la
expropiación de gente que que tiene años
de vivir en un terreno que no saben y no
tiene ni un papel ni un nada y que han
vivido toda la vida y que de un pronto 8
vienen a matar todo a todo es ideal toda
esa vida que han vivido en esa zona y
eso es una obra que tiene mucho mensaje
domingo y la niebla fue la primera
película de costa rica en la historia de
la selección oficial del festival de
cannes
chile también impresionó en cannes con
la película
1976 'ópera prima' de manuela martelli
que formó parte de la sección paralela
de la quincena de los realizadores
[Música]
carmen es un ama de casa burguesa que
quiere pasar unas vacaciones tranquilas
en la playa es el año 1976 y chile vive
los años negros de la dictadura militar
las vacaciones de carmen van a dar un
vuelco emocional cuando un amigo
sacerdote le pide cuidar de un chico
herido de bala que es buscado por la
dina la directora de esta cinta manuela
martelli quería explorar este periodo de
la historia chilena a través de quienes
la vivieron en la comodidad de su
condición
qué pasaba con esa clase que podía
seguir su vida y en realidad un fenómeno
bastante humano donde poder seguir la
vida
diaria sabiendo que están matando a tus
vecinos y que en el fondo estaba
dispuesta a sacrificar la democracia en
pos de no perder lo que tenía eran
algunas de las preguntas que rondaban
escribiendo y también claro como la
posibilidad de que dentro de ese espacio
burgués hubiese un personaje de una
mujer que tuviese otra sensibilidad que
en el fondo en otro contexto hubiera
sido otra cosa como alguien que abre los
ojos que está dispuesta a mirar más allá
no sé lo que dirá feliz
tú tienes la gente
1976 es el retrato de una mujer que vive
un cuestionamiento profundo y un
homenaje a las mujeres olvidadas por la
historia
y a mí lo que me interesaba era observar
un periodo la historia de chile desde el
espacio íntimo desde el espacio
doméstico y desde el punto de vista de
una mujer cómo se filtra la dictadura
por las pequeñas fisuras del espacio
doméstico para mí es en la película era
un acto es un acto de justicia con todas
esas mujeres que estaban en el que no
pasaron a los espacios públicos que no
estuvieron en los libros de historia que
yo jamás en un libro historial de la
escuela del colegio leí un un relato
escrito por una mujer ni sobre una mujer
entonces me parece eso no me parece que
es un acto de justicia con esas mujeres
anónimas que en realidad muchas de ellas
son protagonistas
[Música]
en cannes el público y el jurado de la
competencia viajaron a centroamérica con
la película de la francesa claire denis
estarán en cuenta la huida de dos
extranjeros con trasfondo de represión y
corrupción del gobierno de daniel ortega
stars and news recibió el gran premio en
cannes un segundo puesto en el palmarés
para esta cita ambientada en nicaragua
amarme ya no es
[Música]
una periodista estadounidense en managua
se enamora de un británico envuelto en
una trama de corrupción la cinta de la
veterana francesa claire denis cuenta
cómo la pareja intenta salir de un país
gangrenado por la corrupción el abuso de
poder y las escaseces la cineasta quiso
denunciar el sistema ortega murillo
sigue mojando jaime ortega su objeción
de vida viejo sabio es dramático que
daniel ortega y rosario murillo se hayan
vuelto a presentar en las elecciones no
deberían hacerlo y por otro lado quería
denunciar que personas como ese inglés
puedan cerrar contratos sobre reservas
petroleras ubicadas en la frontera con
costa rica con un interés político y no
denunció a nicaragua sino más bien a la
influencia estadounidense sobre
centroamérica suponemos que el fin de no
suscrito la nannis desde tallin y
solamente son halal
para weber farc a las cintas se inspira
en la novela del mismo nombre de denis
johnson ambientada en la revolución
sandinista de los años 80 claro don y la
actualizó en plena pandemia de kobe y
tenía el objetivo inicial de rodar en
nicaragua en fila vida con demi luego
empezó la pandemia por razones
sanitarias y como la vacuna era cubana
las compañías de seguros se rehusaron a
asegurar un rodaje en nicaragua conocía
un poco panamá y pudimos trabajar con
una productora panameña rodamos durante
las elecciones de noviembre pasado y a
panamá
llegar refugiados nicaragüenses en el
set fue una profesora nicaragüense la
que enseñó a los actores a hablar como
en nicaragua arregló la mud y nicaragua
la acción de nicaragua
como vida a claire denis quiso entregar
un mensaje a los nicaragüenses desde
cádiz
todo me gusta
en nicaragua pero
las elecciones fue para mí una tristeza
muy grande
[Música]
gracias melisa barry con esto ponemos
punto final este programa especial que
les presentamos desde el festival de
cine de cannes muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]